en nuestro vídeo anterior practicamos un
poco la suma de decimales que contenían
decimos ahora vamos a hacer algunos
ejemplos más complicados
digamos que queremos sumar 4 + 5.7 o
podemos leer este segundo número como 5
y 7 decimos pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo la manera en que mi
cerebro aborda esto es tratando de
separar los enteros de los décimos así
que podemos ver esto como 4 + 5 + 7
decimos todo lo que hice aquí fue
separar el 5.7 en cinco y siete décimos
y la razón por la que a mi cerebro le
gusta hacer eso es que entonces puedo
decir ok 45 es igual a 9 y luego
simplemente tengo que sumar los 7
décimos y el resultado va a ser igual a
9 y 7 decimos que puedo reescribir como
9.7 y aunque en futuros vídeos vamos a
aprender otras formas de sumar decimales
especialmente más largos y más
complicados
es la forma en que mi cerebro suma 45.7
especialmente si lo tengo que hacer en
la mente diego ok 459 y luego tengo los
siete décimos así que esto es nueve y
siete décimos 19.7 ahora vamos a hacer
otro ejemplo en el que los dos números
tengan decimales digamos que queremos
sumar 6.3 más 7.4 una vez más pausa en
el vídeo y traten de hacerlo por ustedes
mismos
bueno mi cerebro lo hace de la misma
manera separó los números enteros de los
decimales hay varias maneras de sumar
decimales pero esta es una forma que
parece funcionar especialmente para
decimales como estos así que podemos
verlo como 6 + 3 decimos estoy separando
6.3 en 6 y 3 decimos más 7 + 4 decimos y
podemos verlo como 6 + 7
más tres décimos más cuatro décimos más
tres décimos más cuatro décimos sumamos
las unidades de este lado y tenemos 67
que es igual a 13 y luego tres décimos
más cuatro décimos sí tenemos tres de
algo y le sumamos cuatro de eso mismo el
resultado de siete en este caso decimos
y escribimos siete decimos como 0.77 en
la posición de los décimos y luego
cuánto es trece más siete decimos bueno
esto es igual a 13.7 y terminamos
déjenme hacer otro ejemplo que tenga
decimales digamos que queremos sumar 6.3
más 2.9 pausa en el vídeo y tratan de
resolverlo hagámoslo de la misma manera
esto va a ser igual a 6 más 3 decimos
las dos más nueve decimos y ponemos las
unidades del mismo lado 62 y luego
sumamos los décimos 3 decimos más 9
decimos más 3 decimos más 9 decimos 6
más 2 es muy fácil esto es igual a 8 y
ahora cuánto es tres décimos más nueve
decimos bueno tres decimos
más nueve décimos
es igual a 12 décimos
pero como escribimos 12 decimos como un
numero decimal bueno 12 décimos es lo
mismo que 10 décimos
más dos décimos
y la razón por la que dividí estos 12
décimos de esta manera es que 10 décimos
es igual a un entero esto es igual a 1
cuando sumamos estos dos números el
resultado es 12 decimos que es lo mismo
que 1 y 2 decimos
y lo voy a reescribir de esta manera más
uno más dos décimos y luego creo que ya
pueden imaginar lo que sigue ahora puedo
sumar 8 más 1 que es igual a 9 más 2
decimos la razón por la que este ejemplo
fue un poco más interesante es que sume
a las unidades sume 6 más 2 que es igual
a 8 pero luego cuando sume los décimos
obtuve un número mayor que un entero
obtuve 12 decimos que es un entero más
dos décimos y luego sume este entero a
los 8 para obtener 9 y luego me quedaron
estos dos décimos es muy bueno que
entendamos esto porque en el futuro
cuando sumemos decimales haremos cosas
como llevar de una posición a otra y
esto es esencialmente lo que hicimos
cuando sumamos 3 + 9 obtenemos 12 y de
aquí obtenemos un entero más y nos
quedan dos décimos espero que entiendan
esto